animal crossing new leaf has been out
for a few years now but Nintendo has
just given it a big amiibo based update
I'm Tony and this is your welcome
gamespot news update the new content is
called the welcome amiibo update as the
name implies you can use your Animal
Crossing amiibo figures and cards in
game this will summon the character to
your world letting you hang out with
favorites like Isabel a new store room
is coming which adds a space to your
house where you can store all your
collectibles an RV campground is also
being added to the game it's a brand new
area with its own currency called meow
coupons finally the update adds two new
minigames the first is desert island
escape lifted right from Animal Crossing
amiibo festival on the Wii U the second
is Animal Crossing puzzle league where
you can tap your army bows to unleash a
character's special move the welcome
amiibo update is available for free
right now but you can also pick up a
physical version of the game plus all
the new content on December second to
keep up with all the latest from the
world of Animal Crossing you're already
in the right place
you